molden district council collects your
council tax
and puts it in a separate fund called
the collection fund
we share this fund with essex county
council
essex police fire and crime commissioner
and
the parish and town councils this year
we need to collect 47 million pounds in
council tax
every one pound of council tax is shared
in the following way
essex county council receives 71 pence
malden district council receive 11 pence
essex police fire and crime commissioner
for policing and community safety
receive 11 pence essex police fire and
crime commissioner for fire and rescue
service
receive four pence parish and town
councils receive
three pence essex county council use
council tax to pay for services such as
social services highways and libraries
molden district council use council tax
to help pay for services such as
planning leisure services collecting
waste and recycling
molden district council has increased
its 2021-22
council tax charges by 2.5 percent
this sees a band d charge increase from
202 pounds 40
to 207 pounds 40 an increase of 5 pounds
over the year
equivalent to an additional 9.6 p per
week
how much do you have to pay we work out
your council tax after totaling the
money
each of the four authorities require if
for example your home is in bandi
the average council tax for this year
will be 1830 pounds
73 plus an amount you have to pay to
your local parish
or town council for more information
search for council tax at molden.gov dot
uk